et nous sommes avec un jean paul stahl
infectiologues bosser je suis à grenoble
alpes et ce michel scarbonchi ancien
député européen bonsoir messieurs chez
merci d'être avec nous sur rt france ce
soir
au delà de sa réputation mise en jeu
selon le ministre de la défense
britannique que risquent vraiment
l'union européenne avec cet ultimatum
lancé astrazeneca est ce qu elle a
raison de se montrer menaçante michel
caron qui tout à fait écouter les règles
n'empêche pas l'honnêteté
donc si la grande-bretagne bloc dans les
usines d'astrazeneca qui sont en grande
bretagne bloque les des doses qui
doivent venir etc a acheté l'union
européenne
il est il est indispensable que nous
fassions de même il faut pas être naïf
nous sommes dans une guerre sanitaires
nous sommes dans une bataille
les masques ont montré au début de la
pandémie
à quel point des comportements voyous de
certains états pouvaient complètement
déstructuré là la prise de produits et
le fait qu'on puisse en recevoir ou en
acheter là en l'occurrence nous avons
commandé astrazeneca doit respecter ce
qui a été commandés et livrés à l'union
européenne ce qui doit lui livrer si
elle ne le fait pas il est normal que la
présidente de la commission européenne
menace de ne pas faire livrer les doses
qui sont produites en europe dans
l'union européenne à la grande bretagne
c'est tout c'est clair c'est net pour
qu'on comprenne bien quel point
représente aujourd'hui astrazeneca dans
la stratégie vaccinale européenne on ne
peut pas s'en passer jean paul stahl on
peut si on peut on pourrait s'en passer
d'autant qu'il ya un autre vaccin
américain qui arrivent sur le marché
très très prochainement et au salon
pourrait prendre du retard
ça nous ferait prendre du retard tout à
fait incontestablement donc le la bonne
marche des choses c'était quand même qui
est un respect de part et d'autre des
deux ce qui a été de ce qui a été conclu
je suis loin d'être au fait du détail et
des contrats mais
s'il ya un contrat qui a respecté il me
paraît logique de l'autre côté y ait des
mesures de rétorsion vous êtes rassurés
lorsque vous voyez c'est différent
dirigeants européens qui se font
vacciner avec astrazeneca justement pour
redonner confiance dans ce sérum jean
paul stahl voyez pas être assurée je
n'étais pas inquiet donc il n'y a
absolument aucun problème dans toute la
polémique autour de l'efficacité et de
la tolérance de chez max 1 et est
totalement atur est ce que pour sept 7
cas parce qu'on en est à ce chiffre
sept cas sur plusieurs dizaines de
millions d'injections de vaccination en
europe
sept cas qui sont potentiellement est
pas prouvé en rapport avec le vaccin est
ce que sept cas doivent conduire à
l'arrêt d'une vaccination
c'est absolument absurde à ce moment là
il aurait fallu arrêter la prescription
de la pilule contraceptive qui donne
beaucoup plus de thrombose que que le
que le vaccin
il aurait fallu arrêter la pénicilline
qui donne beaucoup plus d'accidents que
ce vaccin donc sur le plan scientifique
on est dans l'absurde si on se met par
contre sur le plan politique ou sur le
plan sociologique
là j'ai pas de vraies compétences pour
pour exprimer une opinion mais pour ce
qui est de la science
c'est absurde en france la maire de
paris anne hidalgo a appelé aujourd'hui
à ouvrir la vaccination à tous les
français la seule chose qui brigue la
vaccination c'est le nombre de doses lui
a répondu le porte parole du
gouvernement gabriela talent
le problème est donc aujourd'hui
uniquement d'ordre européens mais c'est
le cas à manquer excusez-moi j'ai mal je
malentendu la chaîne d'autres questions
le problème aujourd'hui sur ses
livraisons de doses qui ont un impact
direct sur la stratégie vaccinale en
france notamment
ce problème et il y vient de l'union
européenne il vient pas de l'union
européenne écoutez il vient de du fait
que les doses qui ont été commandés nous
les recevrons l'union européenne dont je
rappelle qu'elle n'a jamais eue
compétences en matière de santé et que
du fait de la pandémie
elle s'est emparée et a pris à bras le
corps ce dossier on ne peut que s'en
féliciter
on reproche tellement l'union européenne
d'être inefficace incompétente et
inutile que pour une fois où j'ai fait
les choses
on devrait très contents non seulement
effet un plan de relance de centaines de
milliards de d'euros pour permettre aux
au pays et aux entreprises de ne pas se
casser la figure à la fin de la pandémie
ou pendant la pandémie mais en plus elle
a pris ce dossier à bras le corps pour
négocier directement et au nom des 27
états membres pour négocier l'achat de
vaccins imaginez un instant imaginer un
instant que l'union européenne n'ait pas
fait cela et que chaque pays se soient
précipités pour négocier l'achat de
doses avec les différents groupes
pharmaceutiques sort était
catastrophique on aurait vécu avec les
vaccins ce que nous avons vécu avec les
masques avec les tests au début de la
pandémie
il sort et est même pire donc on a évité
la un cauchemar qui n'aurait fait que
retarder la vaccination contre la
pandémie
donc on devrait être heureux que l'union
européenne est enfin jouer le rôle qui
doit être le sien et elle continue à le
jura le à le jouer il faut souligner le
rôle du commissaire breton du
commissaire français qui est en charge
pour l'essentiel de ce dossier un et et
je pense que heureusement heureusement
que mes en sommes là après que certains
pays essaient d'acheter des vaccins rien
n'empêche la france par exemple demain
d'acheter le vaccin spoutnik russe rien
ne l'empêchent où le vaccin chinois
on a le droit les pays ne sont pas liés
ils ont décidé de mettre en commun ce
bien commun qu'est le vaccin et de
lâcheté ensemble
à travers la commission européenne mais
rien n'empêche la france d'acheter des
doses de vaccin si elle considère que
elle risque d'être en pénurie dans les
deux mois qui viennent puisque vous
l'évoquez le commissaire européen au
marché intérieur thiero thierry breton a
évoqué tout à l'heure une immunité
collective qui pourrait être attentes ou
14 juillet c'est l'objectif qui semble
qu'il semble se fixer ce que ça vous
semble réaliste jean paul stahl ça
dépend tout des livraisons tout est là
c'est donc c'est dans la conjoncture
actuelle c'est un type difficile à
difficile à prévoir mais disons que il
faudrait je parle bien au conditionnel
tendance qu'on connaît du virus tel
qu'il se présentait au moins de mars
l'année dernière
il faudrait pourri mais avoir une
immunité le collective va avoir une
immunité pour 60% de la population
française avec l'importance grandissante
des variants en 10 anglais
il faudrait sans doute beaucoup plus
plus probablement autour de 70 à 75% de
la population
immunisé pour arriver à une immunité
collective c'est à dire à l'absence de
circulation du virus
c'est ça après évidemment qu'une toute
vaccination et toutes franges de la
population qui est vacciné contribue au
ralentissement de l'épidémie quel qu'en
soit le lin portance on a vu ça très
largement maintenant dans les pays qui
ont réussi à largement a largement
vacciner on sait je pense à israël et au
royaume uni par exemple
en attendant cette immunité collective
les
pays européens notamment sont confrontés
à ces mesures sanitaires on voit quels
postes de moins en moins bien des
manifestations anti restrictions se sont
encore multipliées ce week-end la
population les populations veulent
évidemment retrouver une vie normale
quel est votre regard là-dessus michel
scarbonchi sur ces mesures sanitaires un
peu partout dans lieu et dans le monde
qu'on peut noter c'est qu'elles ne sont
pas elles ne sont pas homogènes
la france est en train de re confiné
certaines régions alors que l'italie
comme recommence alors qu'elle avait des
confiné recommence un confinement
généralisée d'autres pays la belgique
probablement vont suivre dans les
prochains jours donc il n'ya pas de
situation semblable dans les différents
pays européens
ça tient aux mesures prises par les par
les autorités de chacun de ces pays
notons qu'en france nous sommes
aujourd'hui en confinement
dehors c'est à dire nous sommes enfermés
dehors pour reprendre le titre d'un film
de dupontel qui a été très honorés lors
des derniers césar français mais c'est
nécessaire
la seule façon de combattre cette
pandémie cette horrible pandémie c'est
la vaccination et les gestes barrière
tant qu'on ne comprend pas ça on ne
comprend rien au problème et donc tant
mieux
alors vous me direz il ya eu des
manifestations en europe 1 depuis 48
heures 20 25 mille personnes dans sept
huit pays européens ont défilé pour
protester contre la dictature sanitaires
d'abord si ces personnes savez ce qu'est
une vraie dictature il n'utiliserait pas
ce terme parce que dictature sanitaire
quand il s'agit de protéger les gens et
d'éviter que la pandémie tue des
personnes tous les jours ça n'a rien à
voir avec une une vraie dictature
c'est absurde on est dans une époque où
les mots n'ont plus de sens un dictature
sanitaire parce qu'on demande aux gens
de rester chez eux tranquillement ou de
faire un certain nombre de gestes
barrières pour éviter de contaminer
autrui
c'est absurde
donc 25 milles par rapport à une
population de 450 millions d'habitants
dans l'union européenne
ça relativise profondément ce genre de
manifestation qui toutes sont organisées
par des éléments d'extrême gauche ou
d'extrême droite par des complotistes
par des gens qui ne vise que le chaos à
travers la pandémie que nous vivons en
europe qu'à provoquer en europe
l'anarchie le chaos et la destruction de
nos sociétés tout le reste c'est du
cinéma
ces mesures sanitaires nécessaires pour
vous michel scarbonchi jean-paul fallait
ce qu'elles sont suffisants pour
éradiquer virus en france par exemple
est ce que les mesures qui ont été
prises dans seize départements vont
suffire à freiner l'épidémie dont ces
régions je vous dirai ça dans quinze
jours quand on aura le résultat de le
secret était tout ce qui a été décrété a
commis là il vient des dix la situation
elle est extraordinairement simple c'est
ce que apparemment un certain nombre de
personnes ne veulent pas comprendre mais
pourtant c'est simple vous avez
quelqu'un qui héberge le virus et qui le
transmet à quelqu'un qui est
potentiellement récepteur c'est tout
simple c'est pas un gouvernement qui
fait ça c'est pas une administration
sadique
ça n'est pas un espèce de sueur pouvoir
médical
c'est un virus qui n'a rien à voir avec
tout ça et qui passe d'un individu chez
qui il est hébergé vers un individu qui
potentiellement peut le recevoir
c'est extrêmement simple à partir de là
qu'est ce qui empêche car l'individu
puisse recevoir un virus et mais un sac
et une barrière
cette barrière et les mécaniques c'est
les masques et c'est la distance elle
est peut être immunitaire et c'est le
magasin et c'est extraordinaire en
simple et tout le reste c'est
effectivement du fallait pas là c'est
effectivement de l'agitation inutile et
c'est éventuellement de
l'irresponsabilité et ce sera le mot de
l'afar merci beaucoup à tous les deux
jean paul stahl en fait que cela gars au
chu de grenoble alpes et michel
scarbonchi ancien député européen
merci à tous les deux d'avoir participé
à cet échange ce soir